Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Connors again. We're gonna talk about understanding symptoms.
Not every symptom is an autoimmune disease, but
we'll try to work through these things to help discover how you can help identify
the causes of your issues and get to some proper treatment
modalities. We're really, in the beginning here, continuing to educate ourselves, continuing to try to figure out what's going on.
We don't already have a diagnosis of an autoimmune disease. We needed to understand
what it is, how we look at it, and how we're gonna dig into this.
So, when we look at symptoms of autoimmune diseases, boy, there's literally your body can make antibodies against any
organ tissue in your body. So, if your immune system makes antibodies to your thyroid, maybe
the more common-done autoimmune diseases, you can end up with Hashimoto's or Graves disease. If it's in a hyper-producing, T3,
thyroid hormone situation or Hashimoto's, if it's in a more hypoproducing, thyroid hormone situation, and you're gonna end up with fatigue and end up with tiredness and loss of your hair.
A lot of people have Hashimoto's, right? That's because the body, for some reason, and that's what we want to dig into in this course, has started to make antibodies against your own tissue.
So, any tissue that your body makes antibodies against, you could have that immune attack on that tissue and the destruction of that tissue and dysfunction of that tissue.
Depending on what tissue it is, all sorts of bad things can happen, and it can give us all sorts of symptoms. So, that's what we want to look into this.
So, there's really two different types of autoimmune disease when we look at it from a clinical perspective. There's organ-specific autoimmune disease, like I said, specifically with Hashimoto's.
You have antibodies against a specific organ, your thyroid tissue. Well, thyroid antibodies are not gonna attack your pancreas. They're only gonna attack your thyroid, so that's gonna be bad enough.
But, there's also systemic autoimmune diseases, where that's where lupus and rheumatoid is really a systemic autoimmune disease, because you have antibodies to the collagen around the joint capsules, and that can affect all your joints.
So, if you have anti-DNA, antibodies that can affect all your cells, and it becomes a much more serious disease, much more crippling, because you can have flares in different areas that can really cause a lot of symptoms, and it's just a much more difficult disease to treat.
This is the test that you look at a lab core test that shows specific anti-DNA antibodies, Smith antibodies, showgrens antibodies. So, you're measuring, this is a systemic autoimmune disorder that we're dealing with at this point in time. It's not just a specific organ, and then you can also have multiple organ autoimmune diseases.
You could have anti-bodies to your thyroid, and then later on you start to develop anti-bodies to your joint capsules. You end up with some sort of arthritis. You could have anti-bodies to the pancreas, and end up with diabetes. It becomes more complex, and typically you see with somebody with autoimmune disease, if it's not properly managed.
Even if it is properly managed, it can always progress to multiple organ sites. You can develop anti-bodies to multiple organs, and it becomes a more difficult disorder to treat.
Remind you of the stages of autoimmune disease. You could have silent autoimmune disease, meaning you did a blood test, and it shows antibodies to your thyroid, but you have no symptoms yet. I don't have loss of hair, and I don't seem to have any symptoms of tiredness or anything like that.
If you even measure thyroid hormone, it's all within normal range, so you're not really having any symptoms. You're not having any damage to the tissue yet.
If you move into stage 2, which is autoimmune reactivity, where you have those elevated anti-bodies, and now you're starting to get symptoms, but this would be having really getting tiredness. I'm getting loss of hair, but my thyroid markers are still within normal range.
So, I'm not getting any noticeable major blood changes.
So, in stage 3, where you have the elevated anti-bodies, you have the symptoms, and now you're getting tissue-destruction with the thyroid, you'd have marked changes with your thyroid hormone.
If it was rheumatoid arthritis, you'd have elevated rheumatoid factor, you'd have symptoms of joint pain, and now you would show in stage 3, arthritic spurt, arthritic swelling in the joints, typically in the hands with rheumatoid.
In stage 2, if you had rheumatoid, you'd have symptoms of joint stiffness and joint soared us, but you take an x-ray and all looks clean, you don't have any joints swelling yet.
So, it moves into these stages, and whether you are properly managing it, you're trying to push it back into stage 2. You might still have some symptoms, you're calming down the symptoms, you may never get a change in the tissue-destruction, of course.
If you have rheumatoid arthritis, you're in stage 3, and you're trying to treat it, you're never going to change those nodules of the joints, but you can help manage the symptoms and help manage the pain and calm that down.
And then, understanding, again, the clinical evaluation of autoimmune antibodies, increased levels of tissue antibodies, additionally, lead to what you clinically assess a person, or you're clinically assessing yourself and you're noticing signs and symptoms.
Now, that's the next step, and that's what we're talking about here. If you don't have any signs and symptoms, and you do show you did a blood test for some other reason, and you show tissue antibodies, you're in that first stage of autoimmunity, silent autoimmunity.
That is the time to start doing something about it. Really, you don't just wait. Oh, I am tissue antibodies, but I don't have any signs and symptoms and you do nothing about it. That's why getting proper assessment and running some blood work can be very beneficial to help prevent further issues.
If you have signs and symptoms presence, then you're looking at, you know, are you in stage 2 or stage 3, you want to get further tested, you want to monitor progress, you want to try to keep yourself in those early stages as best as you possibly can.
Many people ask, why in the world are so many people getting autoimmune diseases? It just seems like it's a pandemic of autoimmune diseases. It really is. One could say that it's not really, if you're going to get an autoimmune disease, it's autoimmune disease that you're going to get.
And why is that? Well, there's a lot of microorganisms, viruses, bacteria, parasites, and fungi, and things that we are exposed to, lime disease, and things that can lead to an autoimmune attack and creation of self antibodies.
Those are been around with us forever, right? So there's no really new organisms, really, per se. They might be weaponized, that might be an increased cause of autoimmune issues.
But xenomionics, meaning chemicals in our atmosphere, this is the big change when we talk about the rise of autoimmune disease. We are exposed to more chemicals, more toxins than our ancestors ever could dream of.
Chemical companies are making new chemicals, literally at a weekly basis, we're exposed to those in our environment. They're making our lives simpler, they're making our lives easier. Our clothes are not our flavor tarted, we're sleeping on flavor tarted sheets, we're putting that in our furniture material.
We're exposed to chemicals in our environment so that we don't have weeds in our lawn, we go on and on, and that's not what this is for. But we're exposed to chemicals that our body has to deal with.
If you don't get rid of them through your detoxification pathways, and believe me, we're exposed to way more toxins than even if you have the healthiest detoxification pathways.
The chance that you're going to get rid of all the toxins that you're exposed to are pretty much zero. These things then settle into your body, they get into your extracellular spaces, they can get into the cells, your immune system can elicit an attack on them because your immune system is supposed to kill four invaders.
Can you ever kill something like a chemical in your body? You can't, it's not living organisms, so you'll formulate this attack on it, you'll attack the immune system, we'll try to initially put out T cells and natural killer cells to kill this pathogen that isn't killable.
And when it does that over and over again pretty soon, you can fire a B cell or a TH2 reaction, and then you make antibodies against it.
You can't make antibodies against a chemical, but if that chemical gets inside of a cell, your body will make antibodies against that cell.
And in the sense of at least we'll kill that cell and sacrifice that cell and by doing so, this is the survivability of the whole body.
And you know you have antibodies to different tissues that we're exposed to and had an uptake of chemicals that are circulating your body.
And that's how the major reason I believe on why we have such an uptake of autoimmune diseases.
We're exposed to so many chemicals that our body can't get rid of them fast enough. They settle in cells and our immune systems proper attempt to try to get us to survive.
It creates antibodies against that cell so that we had a cell destruction.
And if it was a bacteria there, then the cell would be destroyed and that your immune system would be able to kill the bacteria.
But even once the cell is destroyed, that chemical that's in there still exists that I'd have a half-life of 15 billion years, the chemical's not dying.
So we might destroy ourself tissue and that chemical that is going to go and be disposed of somewhere else in the body.
And you can end up with creating antibodies to that tissue.
And understand such as one chemical, it's millions of molecules of these different chemicals that we're exposed to on a daily basis.
And you just don't have even healthy enough phase one, phase two pathways in the liver to get rid of all these things.
We're exposed to just the quantity of things that we just aren't able to get rid of.
So then you can talk about nutrition and gluten as an issue because that has been molecularly modified and hybridized in order to produce a greater amount of and GMO foods.
Things that have been sprayed with chemicals and foods that have been altered from their normal natural setting to be able to produce some sort of product that farmers can make more money, that it can feed more people.
Well, these things are molecular components of our food have changed and then our body reacts to that differently.
And that's how we can make antibodies against those foods and then against tissues that there can be molecular mimicry of specifically with gluten and the thyroid gland.
So it gets very complex, but this is how we end up developing antibodies to self tissue.
And the bottom line is, well, okay, I have these antibodies to self tissue.
What am I going to do about it?
How do I balance this?
How do I manage this disease?
And it really all gets down to what has been termed as self tolerance, central tolerance, self tolerance.
Your body's ability to tolerate these immune spikes and that's really the bottom line.
And when we talk about managing an autoimmune disease, it's really what we are poorly managing the autoimmune disease, we have a loss of central tolerance.
And what are the biggest breakthroughs in understanding how to manage an autoimmune patient is to help to manage this immune response.
And you have in your body, and we'll talk about this in later presentations.
You have in your body this TH1TH2 response that's constantly bouncing back and forth, and the TH1 response when it's in a hyper-response mode to kill a pathogen.
If you have antibodies to self tissue, you're going to have a flare in your body, usually, because you're going to have greater relative destruction of that self tissue that you have antibodies.
You have rheumatoid arthritis and you have antibodies to the joint capsules and such, and then you get a really bad cold.
And your immune system flares, and because of that immune system flares, your rheumatoid arthritis got a lot worse.
And the reason is when you get that TH1 flare of your immune system to kill that virus of that cold, it's going to kill anything that you have antibodies to your body.
Which is going to be that joint capsule, so you're going to have a greater amount of inflammation in your joints at that time.
Well, you have this not given balancer of this immune response called your T-regulation cells, your T-reg cells.
And that's what can help calm down an autoimmune response.
And that's going to be a big part of how we are going to self-manage this to be able to calm down that immune response, so that it stays in balance and we don't have this attack on self tissue.
But really, when we talk about what is a cause of autoimmune disease, and what is a cause of these flares, and a cause of a lot of our symptoms, when we have an autoimmune response, it's that loss of self-tolerance.
There's a lot of different natural things that you can do to help bring that back into calm that down, and that's a process.
But it is, like I showed this slide in a few other presentations, that there are going to always be flares.
And it's about how to manage those to keep in a state of remission, so that you could live your life and not be just bed bound or house bound with your autoimmune disease.
And that's really what our goal was, and it's going to be a process of study.
So, I know this is a little choppy of a video, but I hope it gives us some basics in how we're going to move forward. Thanks.